Speaker 1: You know, the last week or so,
I've been thinking to some degree.
It seems as though so-called wokeness is actually
the prevailing opinion.
In a way, it seems as though Wokeness is winning
in the United States.
And Eugene Robinson from The Washington Post
wrote a really great piece yesterday called
Wokeness is Winning, and it makes some excellent
points backed by facts, which I'm going to
get to in a moment.
But when I started to suspect that this entire
anti-woke framing and campaign and obsession
from the right, maybe a bit of an overplay
of the hand that they are that they are currently
playing was polling out of Florida that a
lot of Ron Desantis's extreme anti-woke stuff
could potentially backfire because by and
large a majority of the country seems to sympathize
with the woke perspectives, even when defined
as woke.
Now there's two different things here.
Okay, let me give you an analogy.
When we talk about health care, you could
say the government has a duty to provide a
basic level of care to everybody, regardless
of ability to pay very high support for that
claim.
On the other hand, if you say there should
be a government takeover of your health care,
very low support for that claim.
But when we actually dissect what do we mean
here and accurately represent what things
are, we see that people generally tend to
agree more than they disagree with the left
wing perspective on health care.
The government does have a basic duty to provide
an entry level of care at minimum to everybody.
If you say to people, are you in favor of
wokeness versus if you say, do you think that
it's important to promote equality of opportunity
and accept people who are trans and businesses
should take steps to promote diversity?
When you ask people about those individual
issues, there is significant support for them.
But then you go, Well, what about woke?
Are you woke?
Much lower level of support.
Case in point in Eugene Robinson's piece in
The Washington Post, he talks about a survey
that was conducted by the Nonpartizan Reach
Research Institute, NORC, at the University
of Chicago.
They do a lot of different opinion polling,
and we often cite them on the show.
They looked at actual so-called woke issues
and found that the woke side of the equation
is way more popular than you might think based
on what you see on Fox News or elsewhere on
the issue of, quote, accepting people who
are transgender. 56% of respondents said either
society has been about right or hasn't gone
far enough when it comes to accepting people
who are trans.
The woke positions are a majority.
The minority thinks that acceptance of trans
people has gone too far.
Another example on the issue of promoting
equality between men and women.
86% of respondents say that society is either
where it should be or hasn't gone far enough
to promote equality between men and women.
That's a woke country by their term now, of
course.
Woke as a pejorative is used to criticize
these positions.
But the point here is when you ask people
about their views on issues, they very much
are in favor on, quote, accepting people who
are gay, lesbian or bisexual.
The poll found that 69% of respondents believe
that society has been well calibrated on promoting
acceptance or has not gone far enough.
That is very woke.
And then lastly, on businesses taking steps
to promote racial and ethnic diversity.
Woke beats Anti-woke 70 to 28%.
Even when you ask about schools and universities
taking steps to promote racial and ethnic
diversity, again, Wokeness wins 67 to 30.
Last aspect to this specifically about schools
in the context of banning drag shows and banning
books and all of it.
When respondents were asked which of these
concerns you more about schools today, given
the choice of two statements, are you more
concerned about schools banning books and
censoring topics of educational importance,
or are you more concerned about are you in
favor of schools doing that and concerned
that inappropriate things may be taught to
your kids By an almost 2 to 1 margin, people
are more.
Concerned about the banning of books and the
limiting of teaching in schools rather than,
oh, my kid might be taught something inappropriate.
So there's a couple of important takeaways
from this.
Number one, as another reminder, Reddit and
Twitter aren't real life in the sense that
ideas can be over or underrepresented in those
sphere spheres.
And when you actually talk to people just
out there, you get dramatically different
results.
And number two, even the concerted effort
of how has it been a year?
Has it been two years, three years?
It's kind of all the time where but certainly
we've seen 1 to 3 years of a concerted effort
to go after a lot of these same elements.
Despite all of that, it hasn't been that effective
at actually convincing people to take so-called
anti-woke positions, which I would call, in
many cases, just anti-science positions.
And so for someone like a Ron DeSantis, who's
about Florida is where woke comes to die and
on and on and on, it may help him in the Republican
primary in some states, not necessarily even
all, but it may not be super useful nationally
if he were to win the nomination.
Ron DeSantis that is in running against the
eventual Democratic nominee, because it still
seems that even after a blitz of 1 to 3 years
just attacking these views and these positions,
most Americans actually come down on what
is often characterized as the woke position
will be an interesting thing to see in 24
when it comes
to strategy.